would you say that attack on titan is
carrying your 2021
so far yeah dude every episode i'm
getting [ __ ] hyped for
i think people should just you know be
appreciative of the fact that we're even
[ __ ] getting attack on time right
like
in the midst of a [ __ ] pandemic yeah
i mean the fact is that attack when
titan
it's it could be carrying any year
because i don't think that anything
can live up to what attack on titan
season 4 is giving us right now and
i say this in the midst of what i would
one of the strongest seasons we've ever
had
i would argue that this is the front
this is a
contender for one of the strongest
seasons
in the history of anime yeah that is a
big statement
but like it's so
stacked in every single genre yeah and
every single
kind of ev every single category you can
think of that
i can't think of a single person who
can't find at least two or three shows
that they'll be watching this season
and then on top of that you have the
classic being made that is attack once
you know if i was an anime studio and i
found out when attack on titan was
airing i'd be like you know what just
[ __ ] hold on
just like don't don't let's wait like
on youtube you know if you upload a
video when like shane dawson dropped a
documentary it was like just don't just
don't like
almost i would have been like just hold
off because attack on titan's gonna
carry like even if i only get to watch
it once a week it's going to be in my
mind the whole week
so like just hold off and give me a
banger next season but now they all
everyone's like let's all come out right
now let's let's all have all our bangers
right now in this one season because
like the amount of like
we've had a few seasons previously with
some season twos here and there yeah but
it seems like
every season two or like sequel this
season
is a [ __ ] banger yeah because like
his b stars is airing right now right
okay so i do not know any no one is
talking about it yeah because attack on
titan is the only thing anyone can just
shoot that's right right now okay okay
so we we got b
stars too which is going to be amazing
we've got promised net we got promised
neverland
no one is talking about yes neville and
came out it was
massive yeah um
we got log horizon three quince two uh
quintessential quintuplets two
we got um dr stone too yeah
um huh i sleep i sleep attack on titan
season two
yeah basically i mean like it's how can
you not man like every episode is just
like a [ __ ] like
roller coaster yeah and like for a lot
of people we've been on this for like
five plus years this year yeah it's a
journey right it's it's and it's and
it's one of the few ones where
it feels like it's run its natural core
it's actually
it's actually coming to an end you know
what i mean and you know i i
i said in a tweet that i feel like this
is a we're watching a classic being made
and i i have no doubts that
if like even if he doesn't like
completely slam dunk the ending even if
it's just an
okay satisfying ending it's gonna go
down as long as it's not like the
crummiest [ __ ] ending imagine yeah
yeah
wait for it multiverse i'm predicting
multiple yeah
which i would like to think is not going
to happen completely forgot 302 is there
in the season
oh yeah again you just can't complain
yeah no one's talking about anything and
i'm just like there's so many [ __ ]
bangers this season
and like attack on titan is just taking
over
like i'm sure because i remember i was
watching the last season of breaking
badass it was airing
week by week i'm sure i watched other tv
shows during that time i cannot tell you
what i watched other than than [ __ ]
breaking bad
like it was like the highlight right
like it's what it takes up your your
space and your hype
for like well for what it's going to be
26 episodes i think right tackle titan
no it's gonna be 14. it's 14 yeah so
right now
from what i've heard like this this is
this is me going off of whatever
speculation
manga manga readers so it's going to be
14 episodes i think
14 or 15 which doesn't take it up to the
end of the manga because the end of the
manga
ends in april or something yeah i heard
that april may i can't remember but it's
confirmed that the manga is going to be
ending
this late spring summer kind of time i
thought they were trying to do like a
dual ending where it was going to be
they both were like ending at the same
time i thought oh like an anime
originally
so no no like it was gonna they he was
probably gonna i thought he meant
maybe he was gonna like tell them the
studio the ending no so
what so with the confirmed amount of
episodes
that's out so far what people are
thinking is gonna happen
is either we're gonna get a season four
part two [ __ ] or we are going to get a
movie
oh i would i'm speculating it's going to
be a movie and i
think i think a movie i mean look how
[ __ ] successful demonstrating i know
i don't know they're gonna see that they
probably saw them was like
we can do that with the last attack on
titan thing just saying
honestly like if i'm have to speed run
the hunger real quick
i'm going down like joey joe what are
you saying
there's a [ __ ] type it out joey
please live translate for me come on
yeah because i'll hire a professional
like you know the ones with the
governments when they go to the like
meetings i'll i'll hire him to get in
the seat behind me in the theater
whispering all i'm gonna say is like
personal reasons i wish
i hope it's going to be a movie just so
i could be the first one to make a video
on it
i'll go oh yeah i'm going to go to the
midnight screening and i'm going to make
a video and be like yeah guys it was
epic
that time where uh i i i
possibly one of the greatest anime to go
down in history
but just for youtube clickbait i'd be
like so hey guys i think i know what
happened
i watched it all three times i think i
got the gist of what's going on that was
me with maiden abyss
what the [ __ ] is the movie called legit
okay
yeah we watched the made in abyss movie
with like obviously there's no subtitles
right yeah
i'm pretty sure i understood what
happened
i'm pretty happy i'm pretty sure i got
it i i got the gist
it was like plot plot questionable child
porn plot
and i was just like oh kevin you did you
did a good job cause kevin was sitting
right next to us
look damn this song's good man it's like
going to haul questionable childhood
music good yeah basically but
uh yeah like i everyone said the maiden
abyss movie was amazing and i'm just
like yeah
good time i still haven't seen it
honestly
it's fine well i mean i'm not going to
take your word for it
as a man who understood half of what was
being said it was fine